So when they're in that vulnerable time between ten and twelve,...
...how do you think it affects them when somebody uses "like a girl" as an insult?
I think it definitely drops their self-confidence and really puts them down...
...because during that time, they're already trying to figure themselves out.
And when somebody says, "You hit like a girl",...
...it's like, well, what does that mean?
'Cause they think they're a strong person.
It's kind of like telling them that they're weak and they're not as good as them.
And what advice do you have to young girls who are told...
...they run like a girl, kick like a girl,...
...hit like a girl, swim like a girl?
Keep doing it 'cause it's working.
If somebody else says that running like a girl...
...or kicking like a girl or shooting like a girl....
...is something that you shouldn't be doing, that's their problem.
Because if you're still scoring and you're still getting to the ball in time...
...and you're still being first, you're doing it right.
It doesn't matter what they say.
I mean, yes, I kick like a girl and I swim like a girl...
...and I walk like a girl and I wake up in the morning like a girl...
...because I am a girl.
And that is not something that I should be ashamed of,...
...so I'm gonna do it anyway.
Why can't "run like a girl" also mean "win the race"?